season one of The Walking Dead spin-off
dead city has come to an end but even
after just six episodes fans were left
with plenty of tantalizing loose threats
here's what you need to know the opening
episode of dead city is a flurry of
activity as the show begins Herschel has
already been kidnapped by the croat and
Maggie is busy planning her approach to
New York City meanwhile Negan finds
himself back in a familiar position he's
wanted for murder by the marshals of new
Babylon a government that we haven't
seen before now
Negan has also built a relationship with
a young orphan named Ginny she hasn't
spoken since finding her father's
reanimated corpse but she and Negan seem
to have struck up a deep trusting
relationship
Maggie finds Negan and explains that the
croat stole all of her people's food and
took off with her son as a hostage the
croat just so happens to be a former
member of the saviors and Maggie wants
negan's help tracking him down
Ginny agrees to state with Maggie's
people at a settlement called The Bricks
while Maggie and Negan go to save
Herschel the two of them head toward New
York but the marshals led by pearly
Armstrong are in Hot Pursuit
once in the city Maggie and Negan
connect with a group of local survivors
who have been tormented by the croat and
his people they all come up with a plan
to attack the villainous leader that
should get everyone what they want but
as is often the case in The Walking Dead
Universe the plan doesn't go smoothly
back at the bricks Jenny decides that
she's done waiting around for Negan to
return so she heads to New York City on
her own meanwhile Maggie stumbles into
proof in the form of a green stuffed
dinosaur that Ginny is in the city which
puts her in an uncomfortable position
Maggie decides to keep her Discovery
from Negan in part because she's
actually been lying to him since the
very beginning of the show
but before Maggie's biggest lie comes to
light one of her new friends walks her
entire group into a trap as they begin
their attack on the croats Maggie and
Jenny make it out alive but Negan is
separated from the rest of the group he
ends up helping an injured pearly make
it out of the city alive
when Negan and Maggie finally catch up
she attacks him after Negan gets the
upper hand and brings the fight to an
end he realizes what's really going on
the croat never attacked her people
he kidnapped Herschel to manipulate
Maggie with the intent to lure Negan to
New York but whatever that crazy son of
a response with me
Deacon isn't thrilled but he lets
himself be traded for Herschel at that
point he finds out that the croat isn't
really in charge of the city Negan meets
a woman called the dhamma who runs
things from behind the scenes she wants
Negan to become the brutal leader he
once was she needs him to take charge of
the survivors in New York before an
inevitable attack from new Babylon Negan
is just beginning to consider her offer
when the season closes out
though dead City doesn't spend much time
in New Babylon the government still has
a massive impact on the story Negan is
wanted for breaking new babylon's laws
and he spends most of the show being
pursued by pearly one of new babylon's
Marshals the dhamma and the crow at only
go after Negan because they think that
New York needs a strong leader to
protect its people and resources from
the threat of new Babylon in other words
if new Babylon didn't exist there
wouldn't be a show called Dead City but
we don't know where it came from how
long it's been around or who's in charge
of the government there we know that the
community has an extensive list of laws
because pearly quotes articles and
subsections but we hardly know what any
of those laws are or what purposes they
really serve
any Walking Dead fan who's fully up to
date with the franchise knows that
post-apocalyptic governments are rarely
as benevolent as they present themselves
to be
the fact that a new one has popped up
shouldn't be all that surprising but it
likely isn't a good sign for the
protagonists
early in the show pearly reveals himself
as a no-nonsense Lawman who's willing to
Dole out brutal consequences to anyone
who disobeys new babylon's rules most
crimes it seems are punishable by Death
which means in the code 14 section 2 of
new Babylon law he'll be executed
pearly's ferocious commitment to
enforcing the law is what drives him to
chase Negan all the way to New York City
by the end of the show Hurley has
started to rethink his moral positioning
his pursuit of Negan leads to the death
of several other Marshals and almost
gets him killed too pearly would have
died by Walkers or the croat's people if
Negan didn't choose to help him get to
safety on their way out of the city
pearly Reveals His crisis of conscience
to Negan he used to think that right and
wrong were easy to see but now he's
beginning to wonder if everything is
just varying Shades of Gray
pearly is finally learning a lesson that
Negan learned a long time ago people are
complicated and the apocalypse has made
them even harder to understand everyone
wants what's best for themselves but no
one can agree on what that is there may
be a bigger conflict coming but it's not
so obvious anymore where pearly will
stand when it arrives
dead City takes place several years
after the end of the main Walking Dead
series in that time Herschel has grown
up quite a bit and he's clearly absorbed
his mom's tough as Nails attitude the
first time he shows up in the new series
he stares down the croat and says he
won't answer any questions even under
the threat of torture as the season
progresses we get a deeper insight into
who Herschel is now and he might not be
as callous as he tries to appear when he
was still at the bricks Herschel was
less interested in training with weapons
than working on his drawings he also
struggles with being a teenager in a
post-apocalyptic hellscape Herschel and
Maggie were butting heads well before
the croat showed up and by the end of
the show it's obvious that one more life
and death scenario has done little to
improve their relationship people could
come at you with anything
and I guess I'd be dead after Maggie
finally rescues her son he accuses her
of being more interested in getting
revenge on Negan than in saving him that
isn't exactly true but it's a sign that
Maggie's unhealed trauma has
inadvertently damaged her relationship
with Herschel since he didn't live
through those painful early years of the
zombie apocalypse he has a wildly
different view of the world he and
Maggie have some work to do together if
they want to get their relationship back
on track
through most of dead City Maggie and
Negan have a semi-antagonistic
relationship that may have fans of the
original series scratching their heads
season 11 of The Walking Dead forced
Maggie and Negan to work together and at
the end of the season it seemed that the
two of them had come to an uneasy
understanding Negan wasn't about to be
Maggie's new bestie but she at least
seemed content to let him live out his
life dead City resets their relationship
but it's possible that whatever happened
in between the two series put kilnegan
back on Maggie's list of priorities
even though Negan doesn't realize that
Maggie intends on trading him to the
crow at rehearsal from the very
beginning he seems resigned to
sacrificing himself to make up for what
he's done in the past that changes after
he learns that Maggie lied to him about
why she brought him to New York but also
about Jenny's arrival in the city still
he goes along with Maggie's plan to save
Herschel does that mean all debts are
repaid have Maggie and Negan actually
put their blood Feud to bed that seems
like a genuine possibility they're
always going to have trouble trusting
each other but this time around everyone
might have learned something about
forgiveness for now
there's no denying that the croat is
evil and it's not because he kills and
tortures people many fan favorite
characters from The Walking Dead have
done similar things what sets the crow
out apart is that he so clearly enjoys
causing pain it's his sadism that makes
him a villain however there's also a
certain logic to most of what the croat
does he doesn't hurt people on a whim
but as a means of getting answers
securing power or reinforcing
established rules it's also worth noting
that the croat doesn't want power for
its own sake like Negan many years ago
he has a real interest in protecting his
people but the croat takes things one
step further than Negan did back in the
days of sanctuary he has a vision for
the future that would give everyone in
New York City a safe and sustainable
life
if the croat sees his plan through to
fruition New York will be completely
transformed he knows how to generate
power for the city giving people access
to luxuries they haven't seen since
before the Walkers first emerged the
majority of people in New York would
have their lives radically improved by
the croat's master plan unfortunately
the minority would be essentially
sacrificed to the croat's most sadistic
urges and for that alone he has to be
stopped
from the beginning the croat is set up
as the show's big bad he kidnaps
Herschel and he's the one tormenting
anyone in New York who isn't part of his
group he's a terrifying larger-than-life
villain and he's also a brilliant
scientist who's found a way to harness
the methane that's trapped in the city's
sewers
the gas can be pressurized into a liquid
fuel the natural assumption is that the
croat is calling the shots for his
people but near the end of the season
dead City reveals that the truth is more
complicated
it turns out that the croat is actually
second in command a mysterious woman
known as the dhamma is actually in
charge of him and his motorcycle helmet
wearing cronies the show doesn't reveal
much about the dhamma but she seems to
have a different vision for New York's
future in fact she acts like she's only
tolerating the crow out because of his
scientific expertise the domic controls
the croat from the shadows and at the
end of the show we learn that she also
wants to control Negan she wants Negan
to be the figurehead leading her people
and she anticipates a war with new
Babylon but beyond Negan her real
motives are still unknown
over the past 13 years The Walking Dead
has gone through multiple evolutions and
becomes something that fans back in 2010
never expected dead city is a
continuation of the original series but
it's also another Evolution the
characters have changed but so has the
real world and the audience that enjoys
the franchise
sitting down with collider The Walking
Dead Universe executive producer Scott
gimple talked about how dead City
connects to our modern world Maggie and
Negan being forced to work together
makes for great drama but the tension of
the show reaches outside of the screen
as well gimple said to tell you the
truth it's the kind of story that I
think actually is an incredible utility
to the audience nowadays and one that
they can relate to in that same
interview showrunner Eli Gurnee talked
about how themes from the original
series are still being developed in dead
City
Journey said that the entire franchise
has always tried to present heroes and
villains as fully three-dimensional
human beings dead city is no different
and instead of seeing clear-cut good
guys and bad guys jornay said you're
gonna find a lot of gray messiness in
the best way
The Walking Dead franchise is bigger
than ever the main Series has splintered
into a number of mini-series but those
smaller shows are going to give fans the
widest view of the zombie infested world
yet if dead city is anything to judge by
the upcoming miniseries will definitely
hold on to the DNA that made the
original show enduringly popular
dead City proves that The Walking Dead
still has some life in it and it also
sets the stage for plenty of conflicts
yet to come now fans are dying to see
what the relationship between new
Babylon and the Commonwealth is there's
inevitably going to be a war in New York
over the city's near infinite supply of
methane gas a number of new characters
factions and locations have all been
introduced and future miniseries will
absolutely be able to expand on them
fans can also expect to see Maggie and
Negan back in fighting form in the near
future dead city has already been
renewed for a second season though it
will likely be a while before that
season officially arrives on AMC in the
meantime fans will be able to catch up
with Daryl Michonne and Rick Grimes in
shows like Daryl Dixon and the ones who
live the universe is growing but no
matter where our favorite characters go
next one thing's for certain trouble
will follow
[Music]
foreign